chic alors ça s'appelle la question
éthique mais ça pourrait être la
question cache pas ce que je trouve que
sur cette question de lits vg qui a été
aux états unis la semaine dernière et
qui a créé pas mal de traumatismes en
france et un peu partout dans le monde
est ce que on a les partis le parti du
président à et de l'anpe ont demandé à
ce que ce soit inscrit dans la
constitution
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et je
trouve que ce que ce qu'on entend sur la
réaction du rassemblement siens et pas
forcément il ya pas mal d'ambiguïté qui
plane il ya caroline parmentier qui
vient d'être élu dans le nord qui est
une fervente militante pro qui contre
l'avortement donc qu'est-ce qu'est ce
que vous en pensez qu est ce que vous
pensez de ce sujet que je pense que
c'est un sujet de diversion et que la
france n'ait pas le 51e état fédéral des
états unis s'est désuni et que l'agenda
politique français alors de l'urgence
sociale l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat n'a
pas à s'adapter à ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis il n'y a aucun mouvement n'a
aucun mouvement politique aucun
mouvement politique sérieux d'ampleur en
france qui remet en cause la loi veil et
je dirais heureusement la loi veil elle
doit être garantie elle doit être
protégée mais personne personne dans la
classe politique personne au sein même
de l'hémicycle de la centrale ne propose
une remise en cause donc je veux bien
qu'on l'inscrivent dans la constitution
et moi si ce texte était présenté je
veux très pur mais je veux dire
l'inversé mais quel est l'intérêt
excusez moi mais moi j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu france mais sanctuary c'est une
remise en cause je veux dire la loi veil
a été voté en 1974
me semble-t-il
personne ne remet en cause aujourd'hui
l'avortement en revanche est un sujet
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'arrivent pas à y accéder c'est le
sujet des déserts médicaux et excusez
moi mais franchement ça y est on attend
bien sûr voit son ancien visage si c'est
exactement la même chose pourquoi à
venir à utile en suède auxi version
alors que personne ne remet en cause ce
sujet donc alors si on a que dans le
vautour de votre robe et je pense que ça
ne l'est pas
et voici notre rubrique
[Musique]